you cannot sit hour upon hour
and expect to be pain-free i i shock
people sometimes by
saying you behave and you deserve your
pain and that really is it's a
psychological technique to really shock
them
how dare you say i deserve my but no one
deserves this and i say well actually
through your behavior you're not feeding
the
signaling process that your body
requires to be
pain-free
doctor stu miguel welcome to the show
thanks so much chris uh a little bit of
what's the word now familiarity and
uh i know i'm going to enjoy this so
i'll just let you work your magic
thank you yeah for everyone who's
listening uh you've been on the show
before stu
and in between then and now i
decided to take a pilgrimage up to see
you two hours north
of toronto so at the end of a road trip
last year i
had been driving around a fair bit so i
got used to driving on the the wrong
side of the road
uh flew on my own to toronto the first
time i'd ever set foot in canada didn't
realize i needed a different visa
to that of the us so got stopped at the
border i had to sort a thing out
got into toronto on a different flight
got a car went up and stayed near
gravenhurst and then came to see you and
went out on your boat and you did a huge
big long assessment and
yeah we've been uh we've been in contact
ever since it it definitely feels like
um
long overdue fondness i think today and
one of the first things that i wanted to
discuss is just how different
everybody's routines have become at the
moment
that everyone's life has changed an
awful lot since we last spoke which is
about 18 months ago and people
are working from home they've got
different desks they've got different
routines
perhaps with no gym restricted exercise
regime
what do you see as the biggest risks to
spinal health
for everyone in this new world yeah well
there's no question that
it's too much sitting primarily when you
look at
not only spinal health but
cardiovascular health mental health
every single one of those systems
requires
appropriate movement for optimal health
force movement really is one of the
major languages of cells
and when they are starved of
signaling they will decline and
lose optimal health so that's a short
and sweet answer
people are being sat down a lot at work
as well though right is it just the
little movements in between
is that making that much of a difference
the walk to the car the
little set of steps to go up to the
office
well i don't think that's nowhere near
enough
uh that's a very soft pedestrian life
if we're down to the short strokes of
the basic
physical challenge of their life as
walking to their car
so uh we didn't evolve uh
to have optimal health with that level
or lack of stimulation my thinking is
what's the difference between the old
world and this one people are sat
perhaps now in their houses but the only
difference is they're sat in the house
instead of
in an office uh
yes and they get up in the morning and
they go to their home office and they
don't go outside for a walk which at
least
they did uh before and uh
there's just no question about it the
longer you sit
the more accumulated stress in your body
and uh i i think it's showing on
on many levels let's talk specifically
from a
a spinal position then a lot of people
will have reconstructed home offices
uh perhaps not with the
perfect lumbar support chair that they
may have been given at work or an office
environment
what are some of the things that you
think people should absolutely steer
clear of
what are the most common issues that you
can imagine when someone's recreated
their
working environment at home
well i know what works for me chris so
i'm
i'm an older fella now and what works
for me now wouldn't have worked for me
when i was in my 30s but if you want to
talk about that biblical
training week uh we can it's it's
that would be a personal answer but a
generic answer is what i think you're
looking for
and uh it's a matter of managing demand
and capacity
uh and there there really is a minimum
demand that's needed
so people need to artificially
create that demand in their lives
institute movement blocks throughout the
day i will
often say to patients every time you eat
go for a 15-minute walk it's
non-negotiable you build it into your
program
there's nothing stopping them from doing
a round of the big three exercises which
you're familiar with
a few push-ups uh
going climbing the stairs a few air
squats
you know you cannot sit hour upon
hour and expect to be pain free i i
shock people sometimes by saying you
behave
and you deserve your pain and that
really is it's a psychological technique
to really shock them
how dare you say i deserve my but no one
deserves this and i say well actually
through your behavior you're not feeding
the signaling process that
your body requires to be pain-free
so um you know we can get into
the sub-categories of people who
well they will sit at their desk far too
long
without interruption and then they go
and have
a absolute blowout a physiological
blowout for 45 minutes either in their
basement or in their
home gym and that is not
optimal either if they are seeking uh
minimum pain and optimal function so
everyone's a little bit different but
those are some of the uh
big rocks if i can coin gray cook who
is is well known he's he's very good at
making things simple and grey says move
well
and move often you know it's a
wonderfully simplistic way to
to put it but there's a lot of wisdom
behind it you described
the old world of me there with someone
who is incredibly sedentary for long
periods of time
and then would consider that a barn
burner of a workout
for an hour to 90 minutes
i remember for a long time
i was going and working in manchester
which is around about a two and a half
hour drive
from where i am now the car that i have
is a small coupe it's quite low down
uh i didn't have my lumbar which is a
lumbar support pillow
that you can slot behind your back to
maintain a nice s curve in your lower
back
um and i would go from working all day
i'd be sat at my desk sat down i didn't
have a standing desk as i do now
sat down working i'd go into crossfit
i'd warm up
i'd do my 10 minutes of of warm-up i'd
do whatever the workout was and then i'd
go and quickly change into some
different clothes because the other ones
were all sweaty
and then go and sit in my small coupe
for two and a half hours
as i cool down that would be my cool
down um or maybe i'd put the heated
seats on at sort of a mid-range and i'd
cool down more slowly
and that would be the way that i did it
and now thinking back
it was it was simply a matter of time
every time that i decided to do that i
was rolling the dice
of what what my physiology how my
physiology was going to respond to two
periods of
extreme sedentariness with one of
extreme intensity
slotted in the middle and um yeah you
deserve your pain is a difficult pill to
swallow but i think
i'm getting towards i caused my pain
i caused my pain i deserved my pain is
the next level that i need to get to in
terms of acceptance
well that's that's a psychological tool
that i use
to shock them into a behavior change
and when i say you deserve it i
entoned in that is that it's in your
control
you deserve it it's in your control so
now undeserve it
change your behavior and make damn sure
you don't replicate that perfect storm
but it's a way to empower them but if i
just say it
you know look at you i would put you
in uh as a typical crossfitter
and when you look at the crossfit
community you do not find sloths
in the crossfit community they are all
very keen
people they are very encouraging people
but it's always
encouraging to more and the next level
seeking biological optimums is
usually not in their mindset so
uh they would tune me out if i said oh i
think you should change your programming
a little bit wait a second i need my
personal best you see that's the
philosophy
that's that's fed in the culture and so
i have to shock them a little bit and
say you know biology isn't infinite
you violated a principle of biology
and you cannot have five personal bests
in a year biology
does not allow it um so you're so do you
see what i mean
it's it's a bit of a shock but that's
the level of shock
that with certain people now if if there
was someone who had a very timid
personality
where you will not find that person at
crossfit it's it's
it's just the culture and the nature of
the beast the very timid person
i would never say you deserve your pain
now that's
a very different play acting
where i would be very sympathetic and
quiet
and show them prove to them
that they we can shift the locus of
control
and every time they get pain instead of
recoiling from it with the attitude of a
victim
oh why me you know i would never say you
deserve this to the victim
but i would show them here is your pain
understand that
now here's the antidote to that pain try
it
ah you just accomplished getting off the
toilet pain
free you just accomplished working on
your computer for 20 minutes pain free
wasn't that magnificent so so the pain
is no longer
the tyrant that turns them into the
victim
the pain now transforms into a tutor
and they'll say okay i get it
i understand now that because i did this
i got pain let me go back and repeat
that task with the new
engram that new way of of
moving and i just accomplished that
without
the pain i am now empowered i'm no
longer a victim i'm in control
so do you see there's two psychological
extremes
and they would require two very
different types of
psychologically based uh if i use the
word trickery or just good coaching
really this may be a
biased question given your background in
spinal health for many decades is
back pain the most debilitating sort of
injury
that people can get that people will
commonly have
well i guess that would depend on who
you talk to
uh you know certainly some athletes will
tell you
that when your back is
uh knackered you can't do anything there
are
many people who do uh
physical work who will tell you that
now i spent my career for the most part
as a professor
i could have a knackered back and it
wouldn't matter i could still do my job
but if i was a construction worker it
would have been impossible
to do my job and
so do you see i guess it needs uh uh
context
because having a bad hip and a bad knee
is no fun either
but um anyway it depends on what the
demands are
yeah and you know again i could take it
into an extra
there's just different ideas that are
popping into my head as you're saying
that say we took a strength athlete
who had uh some spine instability
as their major mechanism for their back
pain
well when they're under load they might
be performing a feat of strength
uh if the body detects
a little bit of joint instability it not
only gives them pain but it
entirely shuts down their neural drive
so
they fail on the next repetition or they
fail mid-lift
so there's there's much bigger
consequences but you know i could say
that with
with with a bad knee if if the brain
senses
the unstable knee say they're acl
deficient
it shuts down the knee they buckle they
walk with a lymph etcetera so
it's hard to say back pain as someone
who is
absolutely uh in the trenches as uh
this sort of heritage of suffering with
lower back discomfort
is very difficult to escape in a way
that i'm not sure that other
pains would be perhaps in the hip as
well but as you start to move out
towards the extremities of the body
there's particular positions usually you
can get yourself into you know just had
an achilles
rupture repair i know certain
certain positions for that were quite
uncomfortable but other positions for i
could hide it away
and i could get myself into some places
you can imagine i've got to go into that
elevated position
that was that became a little bit
uncomfortable on my back so i needed to
do an adapted
um moon boot big three
variation where i had to try
to try and reinforce that stability but
back pain to me is the one
that it's just so inescapable
you can get it when you're lying down
you can get it when you're standing up
it's
always there reminding you that you're
injured
you're injured something's not right
you've got instability you've got
fragileness you are not robust
well if the person has not
seen a very competent clinician
who has the skills to really assess
the mechanism of their pain to create a
precise and accurate diagnosis that will
lead them to an effective intervention
yeah they they just feel helpless and
and truth be known when you speak to a
lot of clinicians they say i fear when a
when a back pain patient comes through
the doors i don't know what to do with
them
you know look at the medical education
medics
really get no education on how to deal
with a back pain patient when you
see what goes on in physical therapy
schools now
and how little they get on
mechanical back pain it's
uh they're really equipped in my view
is this something unique about the spine
or would it be would a clinician say the
same about knee pain or ankle pain
is there a particular hole in their
understanding or a complexity that they
need to get to
i've given that so much thought and i
still can't converge on an
answer you know i remember when i was
training
students and uh they would say to me oh
well why did you choose the spine that's
so
hard and i said jesus spine's easy for
me why did you choose the shoulder
and anyway
i i i just don't know but it just seems
there's so
few masters of the craft these days it
masters the craft in anything
uh you know i a colleague of mine showed
me a video the other day of the coopers
at guinness brewery in dublin so these
are the fellas who make the barrels
and it was an old video from the 40s and
how those
uh craftsmen spent their lifetime to
become a master cooper
well you know technology these days just
doesn't allow
very many to become a master of anything
but
uh that was one thing that was one thing
i was very struck by when i spent
i think in total around about 36 hours
with you uh last year
actually a year a year and a half ago
now one of the things i was struck by
was something you said to me
uh around social media and i think that
it was something along the lines of
there are no masters of the craft who
are also posting online
and this you could call it old school
approach i suppose to dedicating to
narrow and deep
especially in something that although
you might find it easy i think it is
the spine is a complex mechanism to work
out what's going on you had to do a lot
of experiments to find out the things
that you now understand
um if you're going to take on a task
like that
i do think that it requires you to
i think if you're gonna take on a task
like that it requires you to go narrow
and deep
and i also
am concerned about what the long-term
outcomes
of degradation of focus and
increases in stimulation are i worry
that we're not going to have any savants
over the next 25 years because
everybody's just one
button press away from giving themselves
a little dopamine kick
well certainly in the medical field i
would agree with you a hundred percent
i think the orthopedic assessments of 30
years ago were
far more competent than what is current
practice today
sad to say isn't it especially when we
have
potential increases in sedentaryness and
the demand of patients is higher and the
ability of clinicians is lower
i can tell you a story chris and stop me
if i've told you this
but there was a police officer from your
area of the world
newcastle i was asked to see him as a
patient
and this was a police officer who was a
veteran a very tough man
a man with experience a physical man
and he went to the nhs
and not once did he get a thorough
assessment
of what was going on in his back and he
was given
very inappropriate you know here's a
list of exercises on a piece of paper go
away and do them
with no coaching no coaching on
how to reduce the cause through his
daily lifestyle
and it got so bad that
uh he couldn't do his job anymore so the
nhs therapist gave him a book and i
forget what the book was called
something like learning to live with
your pain
and you know they started to put into
his mind
that it was a psychological issue the
pain was
magnified in his in his head can you
imagine how destroying
this would be for a police officer and
someone who's who who lives by laws
and enforces them and yet is just held
to such
uh a level anyway this man
was suicidal do you mean
that i am so mentally weak that i am
magnifying
this pain and he had to retire
so i saw him and i uh
showed him how to i'm assuming this is
on video but you know the gig you go
down and
like to to mimic that cricketer's
posture
in the cricket outfield or the for the
americans it would be a short stop
position in baseball
and then how to stiffen change the curve
of the back so
you've taken the stresses away from the
pain triggers
you become a leaning tower develop
athleticism through the ankle push the
toes down
and then pull the hips through and then
i showed him
now sit down now stand up
and get off the toilet and do all of
these things
the man broke down in tears he said i
just did all this
free do you mean
that i've had this ability
all the time it's not in my head
and no one has ever shown me how to
stand up
how not to get pain when i sit how
not to get pain when i walk how not to
get pain when i
use uh techniques of martial arts to
frog march a person out of the pub and
all of these
kinds of things and
he emotionally broke down but that
was the instant that he started to now
build it all back up again
and i you know i can tell that story in
in many different forms from many
different experiences
but uh there's something that may or may
not resonate now look i know the nhs
it's absolutely fabulous for cancer and
all of these
these other things however
for musculoskeletal injury there's a
massive
massive hole and why is that
why are they not getting i had a call
from someone from the uk uh
was that two days ago oh i showed your
book the back mechanic to my physical
therapist
and they flew into a rage don't you
believe it don't you do that and then
you know it was all well we're going to
do
cognitive behavioral therapy to this
person which
um again was frustrating to them
they had no clue what was causing their
pain and it proceeded without an
assessment so
i don't know why it is that way it's a
shame i mean i flew all the way to
canada
to come and get an assessment with
yourself so it speaks for me too did it
help you
i have done here's here's one thing i
wonder whether you ever consider this
have you thought about the cumulative
amount of time that people across the
planet have done the big three
no you should do because i've done
i've done hundreds i've spent hundreds
of hours
in three positions because of something
that you said
hundreds of hours did it make you robust
it's
it's improved me more so than any other
uh routine that i've done it's the is it
built a foundation for you to get back
to enjoying your life
i also need to regrow an achilles um
so yeah yeah
i keep on i keep on putting little
hurdles in the way what are your most
important habits
for maintaining spine health someone
isn't familiar with your work
they're entering this conversation fresh
what are the most important habits
well when you say you're most important
i certainly have some personal habits we
can talk about those in a minute but i
think
you're talking about more more of a
generic sense
um i don't want to use words
that are unfamiliar but let me start
with them because they're very correct
so those would be manage demand
and capacity so if you were to go out
and play rugby there are demands made of
rugby on your body
do you have the capacity to meet them if
your job is to sit in front of a
computer
to do your work you must understand
those specific demands
and then make sure your body has the
capacity to meet them
because if the capacity does not meet
the demand you will have sub-optimal
function
pain now let me just describe that issue
of pain
let's consider laying in bed if you lay
in bed for a
while and don't change posture slowly
you will
develop a discomfort and if you ignore
that discomfort
and continue to lay in bed you will then
go to pain and if you continue to ignore
that pain
you will then go to injury you will
develop bed sores
where the pressure stress concentrations
in the skin
will will cause a breakdown so it should
be easy to
understand how different positions
different postures
uh habitual
movement patterns uh progress from
discomfort to pain to actual tissue
breakdown
you know there are those who say oh we
we couldn't see the tissue breakdown in
the mris well i'm the guy who
developed the laboratory made those
radiological measures
and then did micro dissection afterwards
and there was all kinds of damage that
was invisible on the scan so of course
the scans don't recognize
the damage but anyway manage demand and
capacity the second
thing is goal setting so we talked about
the culture of crossfit and again to
point out
you know i love the crossfit community
what a
fabulous community based on movement and
and keen people interested in their
health
the downside of it is there
is inherent in the structure
goal setting for personal bests well
uh that's a bit of a problem when you
talk to
someone like ed cohn so ed cohn set the
world powerlifting
records and when he won he was
about a third greater than anybody else
so it would be like usain
bolt running a six second hundred meter
and everybody else running ten that's
how dominant he was
and he set the goal of only two personal
bests per year so once you set a
personal best
your body has to adapt into that
state and that takes quite a while
so um i think people a
have a myth that setting too many
personal bests too frequently
biology won't allow that and secondly
the the the number of personal bests
that you keep setting when they start to
get
up there you shorten your athletic
career
so you don't see too many olympians true
olympians who are who are really rocking
it as master athletes they're worn out
go to the orthopedic surgeon's waiting
room and see who's in there
and it's usually the ones who had too
little stimulation
or ones who had too much too much and
too little
you either rust out or you wear out and
then
um so when when people come here
and and that they'll i'll see their
personality
oh i gotta set my next personal best i
got to get my weight down to this number
or whatever the the thing is and i said
yes but that's why you're getting into
back pain
you're just too aggressive
in what you are doing i don't have to
encourage you i need to hold you back
and then i say how about this for a goal
and i believe this might be somewhat
familiar to you chris
i would say to them how about if i said
to you
would you like to be the most rocking 80
year old granddad on this planet
how's that for a goal do you want to get
there
if that's what your goal is you're going
at it the wrong way
if you are more modest in the level of
athleticism
uh now you will be a far
more able and fit 80 year old
how does that grab you you'd be amazed
at
how that stops people in their tracks
and i'll get a message from them a year
later
and they will say you know i'm pain free
i'm happy i'm fit
however i'm not dead lifting 600 pounds
and uh i look good
i feel fabulous and my daughter had her
grandchild
so you know so
when you say what are the most important
habits
there's there's just uh a few thoughts
and uh of course if they have pain i i
just to put a plug in i say you've got
to follow the principles in back
mechanic but if you don't have
pain life opens up be more modest in
your
in your goals uh or if your goals are
under the mark
you better up your goals you know what i
mean it's a difficult conversation to
have until we have an
individual in front of us to give us
context but when we have that context
we will set reasonable goals manage
capacity demand and optimize health
that seems very scalable which is one of
the things that i look for when trying
to find fundamental principles that
underlie stuff
managing capacity versus demand and
setting realistic goals
i think i i almost wish that i'd been
able to
had a have a camera on my shoulder
during some of the exchanges that i had
when i came to cu
and the reason is the main reason is it
was an inflection point for me
so i came to see you when i was 30 and
it was such an inflection point because
it was me realizing that i wasn't made
of rubber and magic
and that mismatching capacity and demand
was going to result i i don't just
bounce back from injury immediately now
like you do when you
in your teenage years or your early 20s
and on top of that the more existential
question it asked
made me ask myself was why am i training
what am i doing with my physical output
here because i'm training
in a gym surrounded by people whose
goals are
to compete to make it to regionals in
crossfit to make it to
nationals in powerlifting to come to go
and step on stage in bodybuilding
competitions
like is that my goal
and it's hard to say no right because
especially if you like the idea of the
glory and the valor and the
the accomplishment and well why can't i
have that
and this has been part of a longer
journey of essentialism by greg mcewan
do less but better you want to focus on
the vital few not the trivial many
and accepting that if you want to become
close to the best at what you do or you
want to actualize your potential within
a narrow domain
you have to let go of other things that
being said some people go too far they
don't train
at all which actually negatively impacts
them i know that i podcast better my
speech is more precise
if i've trained because physical health
enables my mental health
but i don't need to go full send six
days a week
trying to keep up with people for whom
that's their
everest because that's not my everest i
need to find something that facilitates
me long term
and this is a word which i'm seeing
coming up more in a smarter
context longevity training for longevity
not life extension not taking drugs so
that you can live to 150
but thinking about your health and your
wellness
on decade long time scales on lifeline
long time scales and that for me
is a realization that i've tried to give
to a lot of other
guys who are mid 20s late 20s early 30s
look man like you need to think like
what are you training for
why are you going into the gym and doing
these things why are you going to the
club on a not at the moment
why are you going to a nightclub every
weekend at the moment like is that
part of your does that contribute to the
end goal that you want
working out what you want and then
working out if the things you're doing
are contributing towards getting you
there
and it's a difficult pill to swallow
like it's hard right
i don't want to think that i need to
give up something that i
enjoy doing and perhaps could have
brought a bit more glory into my life
but that realization was really really
important and um
yeah it's a it's a gift that i wish that
i could give other people if i could
bottle it somehow and give it to a bunch
of
of different sort of garage gym athletes
um
i think it would probably make their
lives a lot happier
well i don't know if you want me to
react to that or not but you know on one
hand i think of
people and i would certainly put myself
in this category if i didn't
train hard balls to the wall
all out in my later teenage years and in
my early 20s
i probably would have gone to jail so
you know you've got to have an outlet
for the testosterone and and
finding your way in this world and if
you're a fighter
by nature you've got to have that
socially acceptable outlet and and you
know train heavy
i'm a little older now i've got a new
wisdom and uh
but uh so you know there you go
uh but you're right for longevity
i mean the injuries that you've
accumulated the injury list that i've
accumulated that i now have to manage
um however i've got a little bit of
wisdom uh to manage them but uh
you know i think you were talking about
how do we scale all of this up
um we we can talk about that if you're
uh i wanted the first thing i've been
thinking about
first thing i've been thinking about is
why do we even have spine instability
like if our ancestors had bulging discs
and sciatica all the time
they wouldn't have lived very long and
why have we got that now
well i thought long and heard about this
question uh
chris and uh i anticipated it so i
brought along a little model
uh injury
to a joint creates laxity and in fact
that's the definition of injury
in many circles certainly
in medical and scientific biomechanical
circles
so if you tear a knee ligament you will
get laxity in the joint
you've lost stiffness and stiffness is
the variable
that the body uses to
control and guide movement so if you
have uncontrolled joint movement
it will create pain let me show you what
i mean with a spine example
so these are made by dynamic disc
designs a
fabulous company that builds about the
most highly biofidelic models of body
parts
for for coaching so this top disc
is normal this bottom disc is normal
this one has been injured it's lost
stiffness
observe i'm going to apply a little
torque
to the spine do you see where it moves
it moves
massively at the joint that's lost
stiffness
so now you see that that will trigger
off
and irritate all sorts of uh tissues
at that very specific level and not
others
look at the loads now that get
transferred to the facet joints in
behind
so instability
uh causes uh
pain but it then sets off a cascade
unlike getting a broken leg let's say so
you break a femur within three months it
heals
you're you're back to normal the bone
has actually formed a callus over the
fracture and it's stronger than what we
started with
but look what we've done here we've now
created a lax
joint and a legacy that
in two or three years from now you now
have facet joints
that are irritated they're growing bone
they're becoming arthritic
so what started out initially as you
you shear the spine and trigger pain now
when you bend
back you create pain with arthritic
facet joints
and then over time this will gristle and
that process
takes uh probably uh about 10 years
so there is why we have
joint instability um
and i've uh explained a little bit about
the cascade
now let's talk about uh our ancestors
none of us really know what back pain
they had
all we can do is go back to the egyptian
hieroglyphics and
clearly they are uh bent over
in pains some of them are retr are
receiving
positional postural treatments uh
when we exhume viking graves we see
the same evidence of spine instability
arthritic
facet joints at single levels together
together with bone spurs at single
levels so
they had it however you've experienced
yourself
that when you create core fitness
you become resilient to those micro
movements
you create an exo girdle around
that core so a power lifter and a weight
lifter put on lifting suits and back
belts to create
an exo support system to
arrest the micro movements and and
create that stability
now where i'm headed towards this
is i have a feeling our ancestors were
tougher than we were
the management
of demand and capacity was very
different there was no question they had
to be extremely physical to live
uh and survive i now go to the world of
sport
last week i had a consult with an nhl
hockey team so
top pro hockey team and the discussion
was
when we get a farm boy from the the
plains of
canada saskatchewan and whatnot they're
really hard to push off the puck
they are innately strong
throughout the whole linkage versus
you get a city kid
who went to the best gyms they
lifted barbells they pulled on cables
they're so easy to push off the puck
they score higher on bench press and
squat
but they can't compete with the farm
kits
so i get back to this idea when
i get an elite athlete with back pain
and if you were to rephrase your
question and say why is that
i would say almost every time it's
because they have an
underperforming core in the context of
their athleticism rebuild their core
and i hate that word core but at least
you know what i'm talking about
when we rebuild that core rebuild
stability
in a farm boy fashion
we have quite often really progressed
in restoring their pain-free athleticism
so
it's kind of a teleological circular
argument
uh but i hope that at least that's where
i'm
currently at now did our
ancestors have these same injuries no
question they
did we have evidence for that did it
affect them maybe if they were a tailor
that sat at a sewing desk all day or
they were a writer
an accountant maybe they did as well but
maybe they also
had uh 15 minute walks
throughout the day they weren't uh to go
and pick up some new leather to go and
fix the camera from the blacksmith etc
yes
so um those are uh
some thoughts and you know there's even
evidence from wales believe it or not
of the old welsh coal mines those
lads who went down the coal mines when
they were 16
had less discogenic back pain than the
ones who went down when they were older
so was there an adaptive uh
response shall we say that gave them a
greater capacity
uh i'm assuming the demands were the
same they were minors
anyway these are all discussions they're
very interesting but that's where i'm
i'm currently at right now and
can i just finish off with one final
thought think of every great religion
chris
every great religion has one day a week
where you don't do anything now when i
grew up
we had one day a week where my dad would
would insist there's no business you you
you take it easy that day you you just
do
and you know my current training
schedule now
is i take one day and i don't do
anything
and that is the day that ensures
biological adaptation
and i know he grew up that way and
all of his colleagues did that's
you know he was an irish guy it's it's
the way the whole
country did it and in every religion
there is that practice of one day a week
for
the lord or if you're a biologist you
would say to allow a biological
adaptation to occur
and think of the typical crossfitter who
will go on facebook and say oh i had my
day off i
only banged out 10 olympic lifts and
went for a 5k run
you know it doesn't make sense and it
violates biology
so anyway there's a little bit of a
inefficient diatribe the thing the thing
that
i'm struck by especially
recently the last few years has been
this move toward a much more simplistic
view
that tries to get people to comply with
the training regime
um i think it's maybe trying to fix the
problems of surplus of calories surplus
of convenience
surplus of sedentaryness surplus of
information
and stimulation and what we've realized
is that aiming for something which is
more easy to comply to
and just sticks to getting the basics
right it sounded
when you said that i need to go for
three to four fifty minute walks a day
i was thinking i've got i've got like
really bad back pain
why am i going what's a walk going to do
why am i bothered about getting up and
standing why do i have to do a 20 second
stretch where i put my
my hands over my head like this is it
really making that much of a difference
if i stand like i'm standing in the
slips when i go to brush my teeth at the
bathroom and
all of these different things but what
you realize is that
those sorts of applications
are so the bars set so low that it's
almost ridiculous that you can't do it
and talking about the most advanced
methods in the world
not only are they further away from how
we evolved to operate and to move
but on top of that they're actually
really really hard to do like they're
not
you can go for a walk anywhere in the
world at any time
whether you've been at work i've got
back in from a nightlife shift at three
in the morning
and go for a walk and go for a little a
little stretch after i stand up
and i'm really enjoying watching
the fluff and the complexity that i
think i saw go into the fitness world
probably like 2006 to 2016
i'm enjoying seeing some of that noise
dissipate and it'd be a little bit more
signal
does that make sense a hundred percent
that was a
nice overview that's why they call this
the modern wisdom
that's correct that is correct okay so
where do you see most people going wrong
when they try to deal
with back pain there may be some people
listening and there will almost
definitely be people listening who have
it where
what are the things that people do
mostly
which is either not helping or perhaps
making it worse
uh number one without question failure
to get a thorough assessment to reveal
the mechanism of their pain
without question so if a person
is able to get a read on the precise
cause they now have a precise
targeted strategy to
a get rid of the cause allow the pain to
wind down
and b build up
the linkage tune the linkage with
strategic mobility and stability
build appropriate endurance build
strength and appropriate patterns and
then coach it in a way that transfers
to the end goal and as you know i've
done experiments in every single
one of those stages for example we know
that a certain style of instructional
coaching
transfers those movement skills to real
life we did that study on firefighters
for example as you know in pensacola
florida we took the whole
firefighting force and divided them up
in different styles of training groups
and those who were uh coached
in a way that they became educated
as to how they were loading their body
it just transferred
when they were doing real firefighting
tasks we never coached them how to do
firefighting tasks
but they had much less injury markers in
their movements
uh afterwards so that would be my
number one answer in a generic sense to
that
what's number two if people uh uh
they've perhaps considered going for an
assessment but they're also doing some
other things to try and fix their back
pain
they've watched a youtube video that
doesn't include you
well
this will sound very self-serving but
it's very difficult to find a competent
assessment
nowhere in the medical system uh is it
available it certainly isn't available
in the uk
i don't think it's a very available in
the american
insurance based medical system it's not
available in canada
so there are individual clinicians there
are a few in uk
that do very thorough competent back
assessments
uh there are a few scattered around the
world but in the absence
of the average person
uh to get that assessment that's why i
wrote back mechanic it
guides the person through a
self-assessment is it as good as seeing
a master clinician know
but it's better than i hate to say it
close to a hundred percent of the family
docs and and many of the physios and
cairo's that they will see although
there are someone who
some who are especially trained in that
uh then i i have to say
subcategorize your back pain in one
person
they might need more core fitness more
stiffness
more control uh and what are they doing
oh well they're
stretching their hamstrings touching
their toes pulling their knees to their
chest
and that is the very thing that's
causing their pain and yet the very next
person
is overly stiff they are so
stiff and in control they're petrified
by their pain they're locked up
and just to get them to stand up and say
no muscle
hover your ears over your shoulders
hover your shoulders over your hips
jazz knees loosen your knees put your
hands behind your back and float you're
at military at
ease and they'll say oh doc you're
magical you just took my pain away
and i saw all we did was shut your
muscles down i would have a muscle cramp
as well if i walked around holding five
pounds of butter
in my hand but that's what you're doing
all day long clenching your back
so do you see there's two subcategories
of back
pain and two polar extreme opposite
interventions that are needed so
you've got to have the assessment and
you keep peeling the onion
now some of the people i get are really
challenging they take me to the end of
my clinical smarts
in their in the consult and they might
have
three or four things all interacting
together
um you know and then there's the whole
psychosocial
mill you you might have someone who i
say you know i need you to go for a walk
every time you eat for 15 minutes
and they look at you with a blank stare
and
they'll say well i can't do that i'm
afraid to go out
where i live at night and go for a walk
so what do you think the compliance is
going to be with that kind of person we
have an impediment there
that if we don't deal with that we've
just guaranteed failure
so there is a social force now
impeding their pain or they were treated
like a psychological warrior
when they're really a psychological
mouse very timid person
or vice versa so there's no end
to this and we get back to that master
of the craft
you know and there are clinicians who
come to me and they say you know i want
to become a master of the craft can we
come and work with you and whatnot and
after five minutes of talking with them
i i know that they will never ever be a
master of the craft we're beating a dead
horse so not everyone
can c can be a master healer
i just don't need people how can people
find um
mcgill certified clinicians what's the
website
backfitpro.com and there's just a find
your country find someone near you
function on there yeah there's two
portals of entry
are you a patient back pain patient or
are you a clinician
if you're a back pain patient the next
question is
uh you know if you want to find a master
clinician
click here and direct some people there
hopefully they'll be able to get some
some help one thing that obviously with
my achilles injury that i've been
considering a lot
is the role that mental state plays in
the physical recovery process we got
some insight around that
well i i i think i have a lot um we've
already talked about
how once you can shift
the locus of control to a person
they're empowered and a lot of the
psychological dissonance then disappears
the key in all of that is to get the
person to realize their pain so i did
provocative testing on you when you were
here
i purposefully provoked your pain
we loaded you in compression we
sheared you we bent you we um
went through extinction torsion twisting
um we did ballistic loading
uh we did traction
uh we probably did a few oh and then i
provoked your nerve roots
we pulled on different nerve roots
absolutely absolutely loads of fun
you even got you even got your wife in
she she contributed to you
poking and prodding different bits of my
spine as well it was a
multiple multiple vector i recall that
now
because you had a little bit of friction
on the nerve root
so as the nerve root moved you got
friction on that nerve root so i
had to pull on your ankles and your
knees in certain directions to migrate
the
nerves away from your spine down your
leg
and she had to release your head at the
same time because the nerve pathway is
basically a long rope
and if you're going to pull it at one
end you have to release it at the other
to get the slide
and it's the slide that in that causes
pain in some people so
yes i do need an assistant with some of
the tests but
never will you get that assessment
anywhere else than when you got it here
and for the first time we
really learned uh you know it's
this particular disc bulge that shrinks
and grows
so we then did an intervention to shrink
the disc bulge
and immediately we got a better slide on
the nerves so we knew there was
potential
anyway
once we've empowered the person by
showing them exactly what their pain is
then we give them the mechanical
antidote
and all of a sudden i keep coming back
to the site to use a psychological word
shifting the locus of control to the
person and that empowerment
immediately addresses a lot of their
psychological concerns because before
they were a victim
but now they're an active participant in
them becoming stronger
and then you know now we have to talk
about the interplay
they can now sleep better if you want to
give
someone psychological distress so you
break them down to the point that
they're willing to divulge in
information so let's go to torture
mechanics 101
you deprive a person of sleep you
make them hungry and you give them
chronic low-grade pain
that's torture but that's how you
extract information out of a mentally
strong person you break them down
but i just described back pain for a lot
of people so
we interrupt that and then they start
getting their mental toughness
back again and away we go we build it
all back
up so yes is mental state yeah
you know they come here suicidal
absolutely hopeless
i've had people say if you can't help me
doc
next week i'm ending it all some
therapist told me the pain was in my
head and i can't live with that
that means i'm crazy i don't think i'm
crazy
but if that's what it is i don't deserve
to live
and i say hold on now give me a week
and can we start to change the course
and i remember one fella who did come
and he said
doc i hear you're different um but i'm
telling you
i've been to the pain clinic if this is
in my head
i'm putting an end to it next week and i
said well tell me about your symptoms
and you know stop me if i've told this
story before but he said well most of
the time i'm pretty good but when i move
a certain way
it feels as though someone has opened up
my hamstring with a shard of glass
it's the most excruciating pain and i
said to him can you show me that
he said what you want me to cause that
pain and i said yes it's the only way i
have
to understand the mechanism of your pain
and then show you how to uh
deal with it do something about it so he
did this very funny maneuver it was a
circular maneuver and then he got
and you know we we gave him some
drills to decompress his back and he was
okay again after two or three days
and i said come back but again don't
think about lead poisoning
here just just keep working with me um
anyway uh uh he never did have another
attack never once so people will ask me
how long does it take to
to cure back pain well i can say in some
cases
it took 10 minutes of coaching and they
never ever had
an acute back pain again and remember he
was
labeled as having chronic pain and it
was in his head
so you don't have chronic pain you have
many acute insults all day long
it appears to be chronic but it's not
it's acute pain over and over again
let's let's
understand the acute cause and and deal
with it
i met him just a few years ago again i
lost track of him
and this was about 10 years later he
brought his daughter to me who was a
heavy field
uh athlete on scholarship down in the
u.s i can't remember
whether a discus thrower or a shot
putter or something
like that and i said well tell me did
how's your back these days he says
fabulous
he never ever ever did i have another
shot of pain
so how about that for mental state
that had driven them to the point of
suicide
and becoming empowered
uh changed his life that it
became an absolute non-issue so that's
the first step now
i failed a few times too by the way yeah
these are this is the highlight reel
yes yeah of course that's the first step
to take control to understand that
you're an
agent as opposed to a victim and this
this comes up in
a ton of different situations i've
spoken to a bunch of endurance athletes
ultra endurance runners who've done 50
hour long races without
sleep going vertically up mountain sides
in pitch black and scrambling down
hilltops and all sorts of stuff
and they say the same thing that you
need to internalize that locus of
control
but even once you've made that change
even once you've said okay
i'm the architect of my own recovery or
at least i'm the builder of my own
recovery and perhaps i have a
experienced clinician who's giving me
the building plans
that i'm following but it can still be
quite draining
long term dealing with discomfort
watching your friends have to go and
be able to go and do things and you know
that you can't anymore have you got any
more
long-term strategies for how people can
continue
to stay mentally robust during injury
i i don't know if i have any great
secrets in this it's just
a systematic scientific
approach that never really wavers get an
assessment
know the cause address it appropriately
wind it down
build it all back up again and then at
the end of the day i
told you about my irish father he had a
saying
a little bit of what tickles your fancy
is good for you
so if that was a little bit of irish
whiskey all right
but what it really meant was go and have
a little bit of joy
and a little bit of fun and make sure
that you do
uh and that's
whatever that little tickling your fancy
is is very different for each person
and it may have an element of danger or
risk for your back but you just keep
learning how to do it and
you know when we finish this call i'm
going out i've
i've bought myself probably
the most athletic racing snowmobile
made in production in your 2012 how
quick does this thing go
it's an easy 100 mile an hour sled
on snow on snow yeah but i i
probably i'm going out to do some jumps
and
pop a few wheelies and things like that
so i'm not going to be hitting 100 miles
an hour
but i'm going to a golf course and and
all the lads around here all have these
machines but
they i'm the oldest of them so i've i've
got to
you know go and tickle my fancy a little
bit
so i'm going to be have to be very
careful on the landings
but damn i'm gonna do a few and uh it
tickles my fancy
and i'm going to have a little bit of a
push
uh you know over the years i've had a
few injuries
uh i remember one winter i broke my ribs
twice
snow well snowmobile accidents i
came up a hill one time and i've always
told my kids
if you go up a hill and you catch air
know where you're going to land
i came up this hill
and caught air and then i looked down
where i'm going to land and it was a
picnic table right there
i hit the picnic table and i i
broke the table broke my sled broke my
ribs
and then uh it was probably
two months later i hit a log that i
didn't see so
something that strikes me about that
kind of looping back to what we said at
the very beginning
is about knowing i don't know we maybe
we should edit that out
no i think this is that's totally
irresponsible
no it's it's you were you were young and
foolish
what strikes me older this year
i have a y chromosome how's that
yeah we'll blame it we'll blame it on
that we'll blame it on the testosterone
what strikes me is that what we're
talking about is what do you want to
want
what are you prepared to pay to get the
thing that you want have you actually
considered what it is that you want from
life
you know for some reason that you like
to go
close to triple figures on a snowmobile
on a golf course
and you have thought that through but
you're not trying to do that whilst
jumping out of a plane whilst bungee
jumping whilst base jumping whilst
doing brazilian jiu jitsu whilst doing
all of these other things
it's a conscious decision to make
and this sort of consciously designed
life stepping into your programming as i
call it
is something that i really really wish
that i'd started to do more early
being intentional with the things that i
do why am i doing this what's it serving
like what what is
going back to the social media example
what is the
the prize that i win for constantly
being on my phone
but it doesn't serve the things that i
want to do in life so i
upon knowing that i actually see when i
pick it up as oh i don't need to that's
actually a reminder i can put it down
because i
i've got other things i want to do more
i have other things that serve the
things that i want to do
and that um have a little of what
tickles your fancy
is predicated on knowing what your fancy
is
it's not have a little bit of what the
social norms
say should tickle your fancy have a
little bit
get your point of what all of your
friends say should tickle your fancy
or your genetic predisposition or the
way that you dealt with past traumas
or whatever it is being conscious and
intentional with the things that you do
almost always ensures that the outcomes
you get are going to be somewhere along
aligned with what you're supposed to be
trying to achieve you've said two things
that are
uh hitting very close to home to me
in this uh podcast
i push it on a snowmobile
my wife pushes it on cross-country skis
in the winter and in a rowing shell in
the summer as you
know i have to train
to do what i do so it is now
a motivation by the end of the summer
i'm thinking
all right dedicated training now i've
got to get
sled snowmobile fit and then
at the end of the season okay i'm going
to have to get
a kayak and canoe fit do you know what i
mean
so it's something that doesn't build up
too much trauma and i do it uh 12 months
a year but i some well i do i justify
my sled addiction a i like to work on
motors and machines and that kind of
thing
and i'll tune them all year long but b
i it motivates me to stay with a certain
level of fitness to do it
uh it's a good thing um
anyway that's uh i like how i will
i went out i went out with you on a boat
that you built yourself
that beautiful oh the little mahogany
one
yeah that beautiful thing yeah yes yeah
i built that
uh primarily with my daughter in mind
and the name of the boat was sweet
loretta
if you recall that i do with the little
plaque that your friend that lives
nearby had made and i think he had a
spare one as well
yes yeah man i mean first off thank you
for today i really enjoy it
i the takeaways the main takeaways
i think are the importance especially
with back pain of finding someone who is
trained and understands what's going on
um i don't think we necessarily got
to talk about that the first time that
we spoke
not the uh the lack of training the lack
of sufficient training perhaps that is
given to people
who are the front line for a lot of
general citizens to go to when they are
suffering with
back pain um the
matching between demand and capacity i
think is a really good analogy and i
like things that scale
i like things that you can utilize
across time a good example of this
is some of the goals i have for the show
this year
includes up regulating how much i'm
going to publish but i know that i can't
get to the
end result of how much i want to publish
tomorrow
i know that this is going to be
something i'm going to build tolerance
to over time i can't just start
making three youtube videos a week
because it's going to be too hard and
i'll fail so
i'm going to start with one a fortnight
and then after a couple of months maybe
i'll do one a week and then after a
couple of months
so on and so forth so those things in
terms of scaling i really like
um but more than that i just wanted to
thank you as well like your assistance
to me has been very very
appreciated it's been a massive change
in terms of how i see my fitness how i
see my physiology the specifics around
spinal health
are important but the principles around
looking at longevity looking at
demanding capacity
realizing that you do have control over
the way that your body moves
um those have been big changes so yeah i
wanted to i wanted to say thank you
well i'm going to repeat the thank yous
back in your direction what you do is so
important you're very
good at speaking
to the public and taking what
we all do it which sometimes is is
fairly complex and
you can pull out the salient uh
points um but you also do it
with such a wisdom and i would say it's
a wisdom beyond your
your years as well so you're you're a
bit of an old soul chris
and uh thank you i i listen to your
podcasts by the way
that's uh that's about as high of an
accolade as i think i can get from it
from a man who tends to uh
swerve away from technology i think
that's about as good as it can be
so backfitpro.com
if you want to yes for people who are
looking for
our self-help guides back mechanic
training to regain your fitness is
ultimate back fitness and performance
and looking for some of our trained
clinicians who can do assessments and
create a program for you that's
backfitpro.com
and i wish i was a great uh social media
um what's the word i'm looking for
um influencer influencer
that's why you've got a daughter that's
why you've got i can't sarah yeah
she can't understand social media to me
it's it's just a colossal
you know as we said last time i think
you can be on social media
or you can do your work and become a
master of the craft you cannot do both
so um to me it's just a distraction
i'm sorry you can you can you can pass
that on to sarah until she's got some
subordinate that she can pass it on to
as well stu everything that we've spoken
about will be linked in the show notes
below
back mechanic is a book if you need to
pick up one thing that you can do
that can help you to identify your own
back pain it was the best gift that you
gave me
in fact i would say another life hack
that immediately almost anybody who has
back pain can
probably look at implementing would be
to get a lumbar pillow
um i have so many now there's one in my
car
there's one that goes in the bag that i
travel with there's one on
the seat there and then there's some
just strewn around my house
um if you go on to get lumber
which is your lumbar is the one that we
recommend for cars and your office chair
we have the embrace there for larger
uh couches for watching the telly we
have one for sleeping with
if people sleep on their back or you're
a curvy woman
for example and you sleep on your side
it fills in the middle of your waist
and stops some of the deviations that
trigger pain
we even have them for post-surgical
patients who have a scar
up their midline and a middle tenderness
and the whole middle is scalloped out
and just puts pressure
on either side so there's several
variants
and they were all developed uh because
of need
and requests by specific individuals
where can people go to get that
backfitpro.com once again okay fantastic
stu
and they ship worldwide thank you man
it's uh it's such a shame i was looking
forward to coming to see you again last
year but
a global pandemic stopped us but it will
be it will be soon i will get to see you
again
well come in the winter next time you'll
have a a different experience
on your turbo your turbocharged
snowmobile
it's not turbocharged no i will be if
you get finished with it if you don't if
someone doesn't stop you from tinkering
with it you're gonna put a supercharger
on it
no i don't need a supercharger uh
if you give me a cold like it's minus 20
out there now
you get it it's you know i'm pushing 140
horsepower
right now and if you get it's a
two-stroke engine
uh minus 20 when you crack the throttle
uh you you cannot get any more traction
that one
than what i'm gonna get now so a turbo
charge
if you want to go 140 miles an hour
you will need a turbo i don't
just take it steady okay
please for the love of god look thank
you
so much for your time uh fantastic
thanks again chris for all you do
you